more girls and women are affected by FGM
in the UK than in any other country in
Europe an estimated 140,000 women and
girls who live here had to go through it
many of them are migrants from Africa I
meet Nemco she came to the UK from
Somalia as a little girl but during a
summer trip to their home country the
family decided to have her cut she was 7
years old 25 years later she's now an
outspoken activist who's changed the
tone of the debate on FGM in Britain it
was very much something that identified
to you and I seem to think well I've had
FGM I'm over it and I'm going on with my
life and I really wanted that
conversation to carry on but then I
realised that if I did not come forward
and say hey I'm one of the people that
had it but I'm always I'm also on the
other side then people were thinking
well if you could have left here and
then it could be anywhere and I'm like
exactly it's nothing to do with not
being educated to what all these things
is to do with the lack of agency within
girls and within like a ghost be
protected but I know a lot of women in
this room are being like you know we do
so many things and I want to give him
the confidence there and also everybody
else that it's not you that's our fault
is persist it's a society and my issue
that's our fault and we can't and you
can't get over it it was like just
normal that really key to the issue
female genital mutilation was made
illegal in the UK in the 1980s but in
some parts of London the proportion of
women cut is estimated at up to five
percent the highest rate is in the
borough of Southwark in South London
during summer vacation young girls are
often sent back to the home country of
their parents and cut their
apparently 5% of women that's the
estimates around here like to have been
affected by it yeah no I would never do
that ever ever ever thus so how do they
even get that
pleasure offices I wouldn't accept it in
this country because it's not part of
the culture here in the UK so I wouldn't
really accept it but if peopIe against
it because they're doing it in Africa
I think they should this is the culture
so we can't leave our culture and then
go to other people's culture and tell
them what to do
they've been doing it for years so the
sheer ignorance it's not it's nothing to
do with religion it's not it's nothing I
don't think it's anything well if it is
something to do with culture it's it's a
crass culture that I mean - I can't find
the right detective but it's its culture
that needs to go
I learn about the devastating
psychological effects of FGM from this
young woman nine years ago she left her
home in Gambia and freed herself from a
forced marriage
fearing the hatred and hostility of her
family and the African community she
wants to remain anonymous this is the
first time she tells her story publicly
he said are we going to have party we're
gonna buy a nice dress for you I used to
love banana later on you're gonna buy
banana for me so I just follow her you
get into a car then we go they left me
with the lady and her friends so I did
undress me I was naked they put me down
on a floor I lied they're like like this
face up I was lying on my back so they
hold my hand somebody have to sit here
someone pinned you yeah put me down and
somebody was holding my legs one is
holding this one one is holding that one
they just caught I can remember what
type of math do they use but they use
knife what I was feeling the pain and I
didn't see anyone I know I know I was
young because I was seven nearly eight
so I need someone at least that I know
but no I just I just seen strangers and
they just left you there I just loved it
yeah they just left me there and they
take the order one I was the first to do
and they take the other one so that one
was reading reading reading reading but
they didn't care one day when she was
getting her first baby and the first and
the only one lesson left in the group
the only one left and
so we'll stop
when I'm having sex like you know people
like they try because they like because
of pleasure for me I cry because it's
painful for the past three years I
didn't have sex because so paying for I
can't so any man that I met he will just
leave with me for once that's it you
will not want to see me again and
brought coming out of me still now I
know that when I will live with it for
the rest of my life I never tell it to
anyone unless doctors the young woman
has applied for asylum in Britain she
doesn't want to go back to Gambia under
any circumstances she's afraid her
father will kill her men play a decisive
role when it comes to upholding the
abuse that is FGM Solomon is one of the
few male activists who fight against FGM
he's regularly trying to convince men to
spare their daughters why do you think
it's important for men to get involved
in the fight to stop this because I have
always argued that FGM is done on women
but it's done for for men that is the
underlying cause the underlying reason
to control the sexuality of you know the
the woman and so that she stays loyal
and obedient to the man traditionally
FGM has been left to be seen as a woman
issue and I never get got involved you
know so the main have willingly which
thrown themselves and the woman have
happily continued that tradition they
don't get the men involved okay it is
seen as a human issue not as much
business woman's business but when the
man decides to step in in a breaking
some kind of tradition says no it needs
to stop here then I don't think we can
fight back in suit structure does not
does not was visited
there are only a handful of women in the
United Kingdom who openly address and
combat FGM women like Alomar to have
publicized the issue and put it on the
political agenda now Alomar too is
helping other women break the taboo as
well because most sufferers remain
silent they're afraid of how their
communities will react activists who
speak out I know of many who have to
move away from their homes because they
are seen as threats what does that
backlash look like specifically I would
give you from the snares that people
walking in the street and going like
this in your face or getting eggs thrown
at your face this is literal or you have
comments on social media or you get
letters in the polls so for any woman
they have to also be working and be
faced with this reality that they are in
that I'm gonna go back and face my
family I'm going to go back and face
those people that I said have done this
to me and they want to be loved they
want to be cared for they want to belong
somewhere because what you don't want is
to have women feeling even more so
ostracize often Alomar - is the first
stop for women who need assistance the
young woman who wishes to remain
anonymous has contacted her and with a
LeMat whose help she managed to finally
talk about the violence done to her
what's your dream for the future my
dream it's like to work right charities
helping girls that goes like girls that
they've forced to get marry or early
marriages or this FGM I just want people
to stop it so I'm gonna like be an
activist on that it was that important
to you yeah because I know what I go
through so I don't want people to be
victim like me or I don't know victim
survivors like me I want to help
survivors like me so that they can come
out and speak to themselves